ja ich meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ich begrüße sie zur
pressekonferenz nach den landtagswahlen
in hessen mit der cdu parteivorsitzenden
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und dem
stellvertretenden cdu vorsitzenden und
hessischen ministerpräsidenten volker
bouffier und kanzlerin beginnt ja meine
damen und herren die nackten zahlen des
ergebnisses der cdu bei der landtagswahl
in hessen sind überaus enttäuschend sie
sind bitter und zwar sowohl für unsere
freundinnen und freunde in hessen als
auch für uns im bund und da hilft es
auch nichts dass auch diese landtagswahl
wie jede landtagswahl zunächst einmal
nichts anderes war als eine landtagswahl
denn es steht außer zweifel dass unsere
freunde in hessen deutlich bessere
ergebnisse hätten erzielen können wenn
sie nicht unter den negativen
bundespolitischen einfluss gestanden
hätten
und das ist umso bedauerlicher und das
sage ich ganz besonders zu volker
bouffier
weil die schwarz grüne landesregierung
in hessen eine überzeugende bilanz
vorweisen konnte auf deren grundlage sie
um das vertrauen der bürgerinnen und
bürger geworben hat erfolgreiche bilanz
sowohl im blick auf die sacharbeit als
auch im blick auf den stil des umgangs
zweier ja durchaus sehr
unterschiedlicher partner also die cdu
konnte die bürgerinnen und bürgern nicht
ausreichend überzeugen und damit an
dieser stelle nicht das geringste
missverständnis entsteht weil sich nicht
etwa den wählerinnen und wählern hierfür
die schuld zu in einem gegenteil ich
danke denen die uns trotzdem das
vertrauen geschenkt haben und es ist
immerhin gelungen dass die cdu wieder
mit abstand stärkste partei wurde und
das auch gut dass auch schwarz-grün die
landesregierung sowie sie
zwar hauchdünn aber immerhin bestätigt
wurde
und volker bouffier wird und das wird er
auch gleich sagen natürlich jetzt auch
zügig gespräche aufnehmen
aber bundespolitisch können wir nach
dieser wahl in hessen nach der
landtagswahl in bayern nach den
verwerfungen zwischen cdu und csu im
sommer nach der quälend lange regiert
regierungsbildung nach den
vorausgegangenen scheitern der
bemühungen eine regierung von cdu csu
fdp und grünen zu bilden nicht einfach
zur tagesordnung übergehen
ich bin überzeugt wir müssen innehalten
ich jedenfalls tue das und ich wünsche
mir dass wir den gestrigen wahltag als
zäsur nehmen dass wir alles auf den
prüfstand stellen was wir spätestens
seit der bundestagswahl bis heute gesagt
und getan haben und dann könnte in einer
solchen zäsur auch eine chance liegen
für die volksparteien cdu/csu und spd
für alle demokratischen parteien unseres
landes zu klären was dem inneren frieden
dient was dem zusammenhalt des landes
dient und was eben nicht denn es ist
mein verständnis sowohl als
bundeskanzlerin und als aber genauso als
vorsitzende der cdu deutschlands dass
die demokratie von der mehrheitlich
getragene übereinkunft lebt dass ihre
staatsdiener alles in ihrer macht
stehende für den inneren frieden und den
zusammenhalt unseres landes tun und dass
sie sich immer wieder prüfen was genau
sie dafür tun können so das ergebnis
meines ganz persönlichen innehaltens
seines nachdenkens möchte ich ihnen
heute vortragen genauso wie ich das an
dieser stelle vor fast zwei jahren schon
einmal getan habe als ich mich nach
langem nachdenken für die bundestagswahl
2017 zur erneuten kanzlerkandidatur
entschlossen hatte ich habe heute den
eindruck dass ich mit meinen
schlussfolgerungen und erläuterungen
nicht bis zur klausurtagung nächste
woche die wir ja schon vor langer zeit
vereinbart haben warten sollte denn
jeder tag zählt auch zur klärung der
dinge denn wenn die menschen im land wie
zuletzt gestern in hessen uns und lässt
uns und letztlich auch mich persönlich
als derjenigen die schon qua amt
natürlich die verantwortung für alles
trägt ganz egal ob man immer an allem
schuld ist aber als bundeskanzlerin und
cdu-vorsitzende trage ich schon qua amt
die verantwortung für alles für
gelungenes genauso wie für misslungen
ist wenn die menschen uns also ins
stammbuch schreiben was sie von den
vorgängen mit der regierungsbildung auf
der bundesebene und von der arbeit der
bundesregierung in den ersten sieben
monaten halten dann ist das ein
deutliches signal dass es so nicht
weitergehen kann
das bild das die regierung abgibt ist
inakzeptabel
ihre in weiten teilen sehr ordentliche
sacharbeit hatte bislang überhaupt keine
chance wahrgenommen zu werden und das
hat tiefere ursachen als nur
kommunikative ich rede hier wirklich
nicht allein wie es so schön heißt über
ein vermittlungsproblem ich rede über
eine arbeitskultur ich rede darüber dass
es eigentlich ein treppenwitz der
geschichte wäre wenn man schon nach gut
sechs monaten den stab über diese
bundesregierung brechen müsste nur weil
sie sich nicht in der lage sieht so zu
arbeiten das ist die menschen nicht
abstößt und darauf gilt es sich zu
konzentrieren
manche entwicklung der zurückliegenden
wochen und monate ich habe das ja auch
gesagt halten meinen persönlichen
ansprüchen an die qualität der arbeit
auch nicht stand ich habe deshalb das ja
auch durch bedauern zum ausdruck
gebracht ich habe mir immer gewünscht
und vorgenommen meine staatspolitischen
und parteipolitischen ämter in würde zu
tragen und ziehe eines tages auch in
würde zu verlassen
zugleich weiß ich dass so etwas in einer
politischen ordnung nicht gleichsam am
reißbrett geplant werden kann sondern
dass das nur in einer fortwährenden
persönlichen abwägung von freiheit und
verantwortung wie auch in enger
abstimmung mit meiner partei und
zwischen den koalitionspartnern einer
bundesregierung zu geschehen hat
denn welche entscheidung auch immer in
welche richtung getroffen wird hat ja
das wissen sie alle tief greifende
auswirkungen das muss nach bestem wissen
und gewissen abgewogen und bedacht
werden und das habe ich getan und das
werde ich auch täglich weiter tun
welchen beitrag kann ich also persönlich
in der jetzigen situation leisten für
unser land und für meine partei
ich bin seit nunmehr über 18 jahren
vorsitzende der cdu deutschlands
eine aufgabe die ich mit leidenschaft
und hingabe versuche auszufüllen und
seit fast genau 13 jahren bin ich
bundeskanzlerin der bundesrepublik
deutschland ein amt das auszufüllen eine
tägliche ehre und herausforderung ist
als sie am 30 mai 2005 von dieser stelle
aus meine erste kanzlerkandidatur
öffentlich bekannt gegeben habe habe ich
sie unter anderem damit begründet dass
sich deutschland dienen möchte
deutschland und den menschen zu dienen
das ist eine in zeiten wie diesen zu
malen national wie international sehr
herausfordernde aber auch erfüllende
aufgabe und dass ich das nun schon so
lange tun darf dafür bin ich sehr
dankbar
ich habe einmal gesagt ich wurde nicht
als kanzlerin geboren und das habe ich
auch nie vergessen zugleich habe ich das
sichere gefühl dass es heute an der zeit
ist ein neues kapitel aufzuschlagen denn
wir alle stehen in der zeit und für mich
ist es heute an der zeit in folgende
entscheidung mitzuteilen
erstens auf dem nächsten bundesparteitag
der cdu im dezember in hamburg werde ich
nicht wieder für das amt der
vorsitzenden der cdu deutschlands
kandidieren
zweitens diese vierte amtszeit ist meine
letzte als bundeskanzlerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland bei der
bundestagswahl 2021 werde ich nicht
wieder als kanzlerkandidatin der
antreten und auch nicht mehr für den
deutschen bundestag kandidieren und das
will ich nur zu protokoll geben auch
keine weiteren politischen ämter
anstrengen drittens für den rest der
legislaturperiode mir nicht bereit
weiter als bundeskanzlerin zu arbeiten
und viertens ja damit weiche ich in
einem ganz erheblichen maße von meiner
tiefen überzeugung ab das parteivorsitz
und kanzleramt in einer hand sein
sollten
das ist ein wagnis keine frage aber
unter abwägung aller vor und nachteile
bin ich dennoch zu dem ergebnis gekommen
dass es vertretbar ist dieses wagnis
einzugehen wenn ich 2021 wieder als
spitzenkandidaten zur bundestagswahl
antreten wollen würde
oder ich mir heute darüber im unklaren
wären dann hätte ich diese entscheidung
so nicht getroffen aber ich versuche mit
dieser entscheidung einen beitrag zu
leisten der es der bundesregierung
ermöglicht ihre kräfte auf endlich gutes
regieren zu konzentrieren und das
verlangen die menschen ja zurecht und
dieses vorgehen fuß dem übrigen
ausdrücklich auch auf der absicht der
bundesregierung eine evaluierung ihrer
regierungsarbeit zur mitte der
legislaturperiode vorzunehmen die
cdu/csu und spd in ihrem
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben
fünftens meine partei die cdu kann sich
mit einer auf dem bundesparteitag in
hamburg gewählten neuen
führungsmannschaft verbunden auch mit
dem prozess für ein neues
grundsatzprogramm auf die zeit nach mehr
einstellen
ich bin mir bewusst dass ein solches
vorgehen in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik ohne beispiel ist aber
ich bin davon überzeugt dass das
vorgehen viel mehr chancen als risiko
bietet für unser land die
bundesregierung und auch für meine
partei und diese überzeugung habe ich
auch aus meiner persönlichen
lebenserfahrungen gewonnen
denn zur bundestagswahl 2002 habe ich
dem damaligen csu vorsitzenden edmund
stoiber die kanzlerkandidatur überlassen
und für ihn und die ziele der union aus
vollem herzen
aus voller überzeugung wahlkampf geführt
und heute ist es mir eine
herzensangelegenheit in der letzten
legislaturperiode meines politischen
arbeitens einen beitrag zu leisten mit
dem neuer erfolg der cdu und da
gleichzeitiger wahrung staatspolitischer
verantwortung möglich ist herzlichen
dank herr bouffier bitte ja weil der
damen und herren ich möchte zunächst
eine bemerkung machen
zur entscheidung unser
bundesvorsitzender das ist eine tiefe
zäsur für die cdu deutschlands
ich möchte wie dass der bundesvorstand
titan hat angela merkel und fifa wurden
dank aussprechen und anerkennung und
unseren respekt
angela merkel hat eine starke
entscheidung mit rum
eine noble entscheidung eine richtige
ist
diese entscheidung bietet der union neue
chancen die wir sowohl im inhalt wie
aber auch im stil klug nutzen wollen
heute ist nicht der tag des abschieds
ist als parteivorsitzende aber danke wie
dass der bundesvorstand getan hat darf
ich ihnen meine damen und herren hier
auch vermitteln das ist sehr bewegend
viele kolleginnen und kollegen waren
berührt und das ist nach 18 jahren
bundes parteivorsitz keine kleinigkeit
deshalb nochmal dank und große
anerkennung und respekt und das ist eine
sehr starke entscheidung von angela
merkel zum zweiten mal eine damen und
herren wir haben gestern in hessen
gewählt sie haben reichhaltig im vorfeld
berichtet auch gestern und heute so dass
ich glaube ich ihnen die aus meiner
sicht wichtigsten punkte kurz vermitteln
darf
wir haben einen wahlkampf erlebt den ich
so noch nie erlebt habe er war medial
aber auch in den gesprächen mit vielen
vielen bürgerinnen und bürgern ein
landtagswahlkampf oder war gleichzeitig
aber auch ein kleiner
bundestagswahlkampf
wir haben sehr starke überlagerungen
gehabt der themen die hier in berlin
eine große rolle spielen
alles in allem wir haben es als
hessischer cdu nicht vermocht die
stimmenzahl zu erreichen die wir uns
erhofft hatten
wir haben für die arbeit die wir bisher
geleistet haben sehr gute noten
wir haben hohes vertrauen bekommen aber
das war in dieser situation nicht
umzusetzen 27 prozent das ist für die
hessische cdu alles andere als
erfreulich
drastische verluste das tut weh das ist
anders zu demut da werden wir auch nicht
einfach darüber hinweggehen
und natürlich muss unser ziel sein diese
wählerinnen und wähler wiederzugewinnen
zum zweiten war unser ziel stärkste
partei zu werden
das ist uns gelungen daraus leiten wir
den anspruch ab auch in den nächsten
fünf jahren müssten politisch zu führen
und die landesregierung zu führen
sie kennen die ergebnisse hessen ist
traditionell klappt das war auch diesmal
wieder so der letzte sitz ist glaube ich
um 2 uhr vier sozusagen gekippt so dass
wir jetzt die möglichkeit haben die
bisherige koalition fortzuführen mit
einem sitz es gibt aber auch noch andere
möglichkeiten
das wird abzuwarten sein ich habe die
absicht heute nachmittag den gremien
hessischen cdu vorzuschlagen dass wir
die sozialdemokraten die grünen und die
fdp zum gespräch geladen
ich beabsichtige relativ schnell
klarheit darüber zu gewinnen wie es
weitergeht
hessen braucht eine stabile regierung
wir sind gut genießen aber brauchen auch
eine politische stabilität bin
zuversichtlich dass ich meine aufgabe
als ministerpräsident fortsetzen kann
aber jetzt kommen erst gespräche alles
in allem eine sehr gemischte
situation heute auch für mich persönlich
wir haben viele bälle ergebnisse gesehen
die uns noch gewaltig beschäftigen
werden
wir haben die freude dass wir sehr viele
direktmandate erzielt haben
andererseits ist es nicht gelungen dass
jemand über die liste ein mandat erzielt
hat wenn sie sich die farbe von hessen
ansehen dann haben sie oben im norden
rund um kassel sozialdemokratische
wahlkreise und der rest ist nahezu cdu
mit einigen einsprengseln der grünen wir
werden das sehr sorgfältig analysieren
aber jetzt geht der schwerpunkt erst
einmal darauf dass wir sehr schnell mit
den anderen parteien gespräche führen
und es liegt auf der hand wenn es ein
zweierbündnis möglich ist ist dass die
erste priorität aber das bleibt
abzuwarten
vielen dank vielen dank der erste frage
geht an frau bundeskanzlerin eine frage
zu den möglichen kandidaten auf dem
parteitag ist es richtig dass heute im
vorstand frau kramp karrenbauer und her
sparen
die bereitschaft dazu angekündigt haben
und können sie eine bitte einen ausblick
geben was so ihre präferenz oder ihr
schwerpunkt bedeuten würde
und herr bouffier die kanzlerin sprach
davon dass es ein treppenwitz der
geschichte wäre wenn die koalition daran
zerbrechen würde dass sie einfach mit
streit die sacharbeit überdeckt wäre es
aber ein treppenwitz der geschichte wenn
jetzt frau merkel als parteivorsitz
zurücktritt aber nicht herr seehofer
würden sie ihm das jetzt empfehlen das
auch zu tun also in der tat haben heute
annegret kramp karrenbauer und jens
spahn ihre kandidatur angekündigt und
ich will dazu folgendes sagen erstens
habe ich neulich schon gesagt dass es in
der geschichte immer schief gegangen ist
und ich mich das aber auch gar nicht
daran beteilige irgendwelche
nachfolgediskussionen selber
beeinflussen zu wollen sondern ich
empfinde das jetzt als eine öffnung als
eine phase von
möglichkeiten in denen auch die partei
sich selbst vergewissern kann dass es
ein sehr schöner prozess den hatten wir
jetzt über 18 jahre nicht
und insofern wollen wir ihnen auch nicht
ganz so oft haben wir andere parteien
insofern sollte man diese phase wirklich
auch als eine gute wichtige
demokratische phase betrachten an der
die mitglieder und die
parteitagsdelegierten dann vor allen
dingen auch freude haben sollten zwei
ging an volker wussten wie bitte nein es
war schon richtig dass eine frage kriegt
ja also zunächst einmal ich kümmere mich
jetzt in hessen zum zweiten um die cdu
und die entscheidungen in der csu wird
die csu zu felder und horst seehofer und
bilder braucht mein ratschlag nicht über
die presse herr blank verbunden ist kann
man auch herr merz hat angekündigt auf
dem parteitag zu kandidieren erwarten
sie einen richtungskampf nun innerhalb
der partei und die zweite frage was
würde passieren wenn die spd
möglicherweise aus der großen koalition
raus geht und vor ablauf der
legislaturperiode eine neuwahl nötig
wäre würden sie dann nochmal antreten
nein das habe ich ja ausgeschlossen
jetzt schließt das mit ein aber jetzt
will ich mich doch nicht an
irgendwelchen spekulationen beteiligen
deshalb sage ich auch zu all dem gar
nichts
ich habe auch gelesen etwas von
friedrich merz dazu kann ich aber nichts
valides sagen und ansonsten
geht meine entscheidung ganz wesentlich
in die richtung dass ich einen beitrag
dazu leisten möchte dass diese
bundesregierung die wenn du unter mühen
gebildet haben auch erfolgreich arbeiten
kann
hair days er mit seiner frau
bundeskanzler eine frage zu ihrer
kanzlerschaft sie hatten jetzt gesagt
sie sind bereit weiter als kanzlerin zu
arbeiten lässt dass dennoch die
möglichkeit offen dass sie nicht bis
2021 kanzlerin bleiben
und was wollen sie vor allen dingen noch
erreichen auf nationaler und
internationaler ebene als kanzlerin was
sind ihre hauptziele und dann vielleicht
noch ganz gut zur frage was machen sie
eigentlich nach 2021
denn in der politik offenbar wollen sie
ja nichts mehr da können wir jetzt den
geeigneten zeitpunkt darüber sprechen
ich habe jetzt keine sorge dass wir
nichts einfällt
ich habe nur deutlich gemacht weil es
immer wieder gerüchte in brüssel gibt
ich könnte da eventuell irgendein amt
anstreben deshalb habe ich diese zusatz
bemerkung gemacht die hauptziele ergeben
sich aus dem koalitionsvertrag und den
aktuellen ereignissen also ich sag mal
einfach die tatsache dass drexhage
tatsache dass die vereinigten staaten
jetzt gesagt haben sie sind aus den
mittelstrecken abkommen ausgestorben
austreten sind ja große herausforderung
außenpolitischer art wir haben im
innenpolitischen renten kommission eine
strukturkommission gleichwertige
lebensverhältnisse
also ich glaube dass man sich da sehr
sehr gut beschäftigen kann um dann am
ende einer solchen legislaturperiode zu
sagen das und das haben wir geschafft
auf hartes
frau merkel ich würde noch mal
interessieren wann sie sich zu ihrem
schritt entschlossen haben und wie der
entscheidungsprozesse verlaufen ist ob
sie auch bereut haben dass sie noch
überhaupt noch mal angetreten sind und
welche rolle hat auch der spruch merkel
muss weg gespielt wollten sie
möglicherweise auch vermeiden dass die
leute die den vor sich her tragen recht
bekommen und wer könnte auch noch sagen
leben können sie als bundeskanzlerin mit
jedem parteivorsitzenden leben von damit
jeder also ich werde jede art von
demokratische entscheidung meiner partei
natürlich respektieren das ist teil der
des demokratieverständnisses ich bin
sehr froh holz aus der rückblick
perspektive dass wir bei allem
schlechten wahlergebnis bei der
bundestagswahl eine situation haben in
der gegen die cdu im deutschen bundestag
keine regierung gebildet werden kann das
ist ein hohes gut wenn man zum vierten
mal in folge das auch schafft und
insofern ist das wichtig jetzt habe ich
eine frage
ach so war seit wann ich mir das
überlegt habe es seitdem wir die klausur
eingeladen haben das war vor sommerpause
nur dass ich selbst eine woche
vorgezogen haben herr rinke
sie wussten seit an seit der sommerpause
dass sie jetzt zurücktreten wollen dass
ich nicht noch einmal für das amt des
parteivorsitzenden kandidieren wollte ja
frau bundeskanzlerin ich hätte sie ganz
gerne nochmal nach der ämtertrennung
gefragt sie haben jahrelang stets und
sehr vehement gesagt dass sie glauben
dass das machtpolitische eigentlich
nicht gut ist jetzt sagen sie das ist
das geringere übel
aber vielleicht können sie nochmal
erklären in welchem handlungsfreiheit
sie eigentlich als kanzlerin noch
agieren können wollen und vor allem das
fragen sich viele in europa was heißt
das für die europapolitik der
bundesregierung und ihre eigene sind sie
nicht künftig eingemauert von der
unionsfraktion einerseits und einem
neuen parteivorsitzenden oder einer
parteivorsitzende also die unions
fraktion trägt ja nun die politik der
regierung das oca brinkhaus glaube ich
auch immer wieder deutlich gemacht aber
auch volker kauder
insofern finde ich das verb eingemauert
falsch und gegen den geballten
widerstand eines beschlusses machte sich
auch schlecht politik also ich glaube
gerade wenn man jetzt mal die ganzen
euro rettungs dinge nimmt dann wird sich
da nicht sehr viel ändern sondern dann
habe ich als diejenige die die regierung
führt natürlich die verhandlungen zu
führen und ähnliches aber ich weiß zum
beispiel bei jedem europäischen
beschluss der was mit finanzen zu tun
hat dass er hinterher im bundestag eine
mehrheit finden muss und das hat uns
schon das bundesverfassungsgericht in
die ins stammbuch geschrieben da wird
sich also nicht viel ändern
ich habe ja extra recht ausführlich zu
dem thema stellung genommen weil ich in
der tat der meinung bin dass
parteivorsitz und staatsamt in eine hand
gehören und dass ich in abwägung aller
umstände glaube dadurch dass klar ist
dass ich nicht wieder antrete dass man
das für eine begrenzte zeit tun kann und
dass das auch möglich ist aber dass ich
sagte ja wenn es mir
wenn es mir klar aber wenn ich nicht
klar gewesen wäre dass ich nicht wieder
antrete dann hätte ich es nicht für
vertretbar gehalten das heißt also durch
die begrenzte zeit glaube ich kann man
die konzentration auf die
regierungsarbeit in guter kooperation
mit einem von der partei gewählte
parteivorsitzende und einem
fraktionsvorsitzender natürlich
hinbekommen das ist meine überzeugung
aber nur durch die begrenzung frau eva
und das heißt noch nicht wüsste gerne ob
sie horst seehofer vorab informiert
haben oder ob das jetzt auch über
twitter erfahren hat und weil sie die
frage eben nicht beantworten wollte
trotzdem noch mal werden sie ihn
weiterhin amt des innenministers
belassen
ich habe was für heute zählt natürlich
die horst seehofer informiert kurz
vorher und auch andrea nahles hat
letztere mitte frau bundeskanzler sind
ja als bundeskanzlerin angewiesen auf
eine gute zusammenarbeit mit den neuen
cdu vorsitzender der cdu vorsitzende
das hängt ja auch sehr von der person ab
also was spricht jetzt dafür wenn das
zum beispiel für schmerz würde oder jens
spahn dass der da eine weitere gute
zusammenarbeit die ihnen dann als uns
ganz einfach hilft und sie in die lage
versetzt das amt weiterhin gut
auszufüllen
also jetzt warten wir doch mal die
wahlentscheidung ab und ich bin ein
mensch der mit ziemlich vielen menschen
sehr sehr gut zusammenarbeiten kann
dafür bin ich auch bekannt herr bollmann
ist könnte man auch keine
koalitionsregierung führen also herr
bollmann
frau merkel sie haben eben selber
treffen die wissen dass wir hier an
dieser stelle hier bin ich ganz schön
ganz hinten rechts letzte reihe recht
sie haben vorhin selber darauf
hingewiesen dass sie genau an dieser
stelle vor knapp zwei jahren ihre
neuerliche kandidatur angekündigt haben
bedauern sie das eigentlich inzwischen
ich hatte gerade eben dazu stellung
genommen tust aber gerne noch mal nein
weil seitdem wir nicht nur dass das land
wieder gewonnen haben mit annegret kramp
karrenbauer damals als
ministerpräsidentin sondern in nrw zu
gewonnen haben den ministerpräsident mit
armin laschet in schleswig holstein
einen neuen ministerpräsidenten durch
die cdu und anschließend eine
strategische situation im deutschen
bundestag haben in dem gegen die cdu
keine bundesregierung gebildet werden
kann ich finde das sind alles sehr sich
sehen lassen können die ergebnisse
herr schuler dritte reihe zweiter von
links
warum hatte noch mal kurz zum
zustandekommen ihrer entscheidung wurden
sie gedrängt oder entspringt ihre
entscheidung ausschließlich ihren
eigenen überlegungen und mich würde noch
mal interessieren
die genaue beschreibung der ursachen
also war es die performance der
bundesregierung oder geht es dabei auch
um den kurs der union der cdu nein ich
habe ihn ja gesagt dass ich über das
prinzipielle schon sehr früh mich
entschieden habe weil mir klar geworden
ist dass ich beim nächsten mal nicht
noch einmal kandidieren werde und weil
ich möchte dass meine partei gehen
freiraum bekommt um sich auf die zukunft
vorbereiten zu können siehe
grundsatzprogramm siehe die frage eben
auch personeller konstellationen und das
halte ich für wichtig um dann einen
übergang zu finden für die eine nächste
legislaturperiode damit dort auch wieder
eine chance besteht dass die cdu etwas
eine führende rolle
politik der bundesrepublik deutschland
spielt und wir haben halt nicht die
situation wie wir sie in frankreich oder
in vereinigten staaten von amerika haben
wo es eine sozusagen automatische ende
gibt und dann habe ich mir überlegt wir
unter den gegebenen konstellation jetzt
auch mehr frischen wind in die dinge
hinein bringen kann
direkt dahinter her walde ganz kurz zu
meinem verständnis sie sagten eben sie
hätten seit der sommerpause gewusst ist
sie nicht wieder als parteivorsitzender
antreten wollten
sie haben aber vor kurzem das noch
angekündigt um die diskussion auch ein
bisschen zu beenden sie auf kam in den
vergangenen wochen war das notlüge oder
was was war das dann und ganz kurz auch
weil sie die usa und sowas ansprachen
dann nennt man den zustand in dem sie
sich da künftig befinden lame duck und
das führt ganz viel zu einem
autoritätsverlust müssen sie dienen dann
nicht auch befürchten
schauen sie alles hat seine vor und
nachteile hätte ich habe mich jetzt für
diese variante entschieden die ist auch
in der internationalen politik nichts
besonderes und die jeweiligen staaten
werden trotzdem gut regiert und zweitens
ist ja gestern in einer fernsehsendung
das war sie in der augsburger zeitung
gesagt habe auch noch mal vorgespielt
worden
ich habe versucht die dinge so zu
benennen dass ein kleiner spielraum so
ich kann noch drei fragen zu lassen die
kollegin daneben hair days und herr
gartmann haben gerade eben gesagt ein
wechsel an der parteispitze das sei eine
neue chance auch im inhalt
viele welche eigenschaften müsste denn
in ihren augen der kandidat oder die
kandidatin mitbringen um das erfolgreich
zu machen
da versuche ich bin ja doch nicht ganz
sicher wäre alles kandidiert paar
stunden her dass ich damit deutlich
machen will ist dass wir nicht nur um
personen gucken dürfen sondern wir
müssen auch über inhalte und zu
unterhalten und ich glaube die gesamte
partei hat ein großes bedürfnis nicht
nur dann einen neuen kopf dort zu haben
sondern auch etwas darüber zu erfahren
wo wollen wir hin und wie wenn ich in
ein beispiel sagen dass wir haben in
hessen gestern die gleiche erfahrung
gemacht wie die bayern die csu ja mal
die afd
genauso viel abgegeben ja die grün
daraus jetzt so schlichte gemüter zu
machen man müsse nach rechts und dann
nach links kann für eine volkspartei
nicht die antwort sein
das geht auch nicht ganz einfach aber
wir erleben dass in ganz europa und
teilweise über europa hinaus das was man
in der mitte als volkspartei hat und das
wäre aus meiner sicht kern dieser
botschaft dass wir wieder eine noch
stärkere volkspartei sein müssen denn
sonst werden wir deutschland nicht
stabil halten
politisch und dann bedeutet das für mich
wir müssen eigentlich aus beiden bereich
wieder wählerinnen und wähler zurück zur
union bringen
das ist nicht ganz einfach das macht
erforderlich dass wir auch konzeptionell
und inhaltlich uns auseinandersetzen und
die findet darin liegt dann auch eine
chance damit die menschen sehen diese
union diese cdu ist durchaus in der lage
zukunft zu beschreiben
und das ist das was wir aus meiner sicht
hinbekommen müssen wir müssen den
menschen ein gefühl vermitteln dass wir
ihre sorgen erkennen und auch ernst
nehmen und gleichzeitig eine idee haben
wie das gut gelingen kann also zukunft
gelingen die zukunft nicht als folgt
malerei sondern sehr hart diskutiert und
ich werde mich dafür einsetzen dass wir
eben nicht nur
abzählreim machen oder vor drei vier
oder fünf kandidaten haben das ist auch
schön aber wir müssen auch über die
frage sprechen ob damit auch eine
inhaltliche debatte voran geht das würde
ich sehr begrüßen ich glaube das hilft
uns das war die frühe mit chancen hätte
es hier viel rechtes entstehen
sie hatten vorhin gesagt frau merkel
dass sie sich vor der sommerpause
entschieden haben kann man daraus
folgern dass der streit mit der csu der
letzte tropfen für sie war zu sagen sie
möchten nicht mehr und können sie
vielleicht erklären warum es so schwer
war diese koalition so zusammenzuhalten
dass sie konstruktiv kreativ miteinander
arbeitet und sich nicht ständig streitet
nein mir geht es um etwas anderes
nämlich einen weg in die zukunft zu
eröffnen und schauen sie ich bin jetzt
18 jahre oder über 18 jahre
parteivorsitzender und da stellt sich
doch die frage wenn ich zu der
überzeugung komme ich trete da nicht
noch einmal an 2021 wie gelingt das
vernünftig und wie kann ich damit auch
freiräume eröffnen und darüber habe ich
nachgedacht und das war das wenige was
mich geleitet hat und dann da ist
natürlich trotzdem hätte ich mir
gewünscht dass mich diese überlegung
machen kann ohne dass dauernd gestritten
wird das ist ja auch klar aber der der
der sachverhalt als solcher bleibt doch
das in unserer demokratie wie wir sie in
deutschland haben ist keine festgelegte
begrenzung gibt und damit setzten sich
auch viele auseinander also die ganze
diskussion jetzt bei der judo oder in
der csu wurde des opfers hat mit einer
zeitbegrenzung und so weiter wo ich
verfassungsrechtlich große probleme habe
und insofern habe ich mir darüber
gedanken gemacht wie ich finde dass es
eine verantwortliche parteivorsitzende
auch tun sollte letzte frage geht an ein
gartmann letzte reihe zweiter von britta
von rechts
ich würde gerne noch mal nachfragen zur
genese bzw kommunikation ihres
entschlusses immerhin hat ja ihre
generalsekretär bekam karrenbauer uns
gestern abend in noch erzählt die
parteivorsitzende wird als wieder als
parteivorsitzende im dezember auf dem
parteitag antreten so stunde weiß ich
nichts anderes wie haben sie also alle
falsch verstanden oder war frau kramp
karrenbauer gestern schon eingeweiht und
hat sich schnell war sie nicht artig aus
es gibt entscheidungen von denen glaube
ich hilft man niemandem wenn man ist zu
vielen menschen vorher sagt das gehört
dazu
vielen dank ja soweit diese man kann
schon sagen durchaus historische
pressekonferenz ihr im konrad adenauer
haus ein hauch von geschichte weht hier
durch die hallen der cdu mal helmut
kohls lieblingswort zu benutzen und
anders als helmut kohl das hat angela
merkel klar gemacht möchte sie ihre
nachfolge regeln wenn man ihren worten
trauen darf dann hat sie sich schon vor
einigen wochen entschieden den
parteivorsitz abzugeben und
offensichtlich diese entscheidung heute
nacht und heute morgen dann finalisiert
und hier in den gremien mitgeteilt ihr
ist das risiko sehr wohl bewusst aber
wie gesagt das ist die beste
entscheidung im moment um die partei cdu
auf die zukunft vorzubereiten und sie
mag sicherlich recht haben mit dieser
these denn es ist natürlich eine art
befreiung von der von vielen wählern als
bleierne zeit empfunden immer die
gleichen personen
sie hat ja selber gerade angela merkel
noch einmal erwähnt dass das ja auch
eine lange zeit ist seit über 18 jahren
seit dem 10
april 2000 ist die parteivorsitzende der
cdu und seit über 13 jahren
bundeskanzlerin und insofern möchte sie
sich jetzt hier eine zukunft der cdu
nicht in den weg stellen sondern will
als kanzlerin diese legislaturperiode zu
ende machen möchte danach kein
politisches amt anstrebe auch dass eine
neue information es gibt ja viele
spekulationen
dass sie sich dann aussuchen würde aber
sie hat gesagt das will sie gar nicht
sie wird im nächsten jahr 65 also sie
muss das ja eigentlich auch gar nicht
mehr und wenn man den terminplan der
bundeskanzlerin gesehen hat dann fragt
man sich ohnehin wie diese frau die
vergangenen 13 jahre überleben konnte in
diesem abend hart genug und jetzt wie
gesagt wird sie beim parteivorsitz
beiseitetreten